howard stern says we have no time for
idiots in this country anymore howard
stern defends joe rogan's criticism
uh defends those criticizing joe rogan
so harrison remains unimpressed with joe
rogan specifically with his preferred
treatment for kobe 19 well maybe
incensed would be a better word to use
that stern very openly and heatedly
criticized the podcast during the
serious exam radio show criticism of
which he continues to stand by
uh that his audio someone rogan began to
speak on vulgar ivermectin
cnn okay keep going lower they keep
saying i'm taking horse dewarmer i
literally got it from a doctor it's an
american company said rogan they won the
nobel prize in 2015 for using human
beings and cnn is saying i'm taking
horse dewormer they must be it's a lie
and then this leads to in fact stern uh
deemed those who won't get vaccinated as
uh needless to say yahoo undertones are
commonly got himself some criticism all
i said was everyone should get the
vaccine it should be mandatory this
brought down a slew of publicity like i
haven't even seen ever before it's
mind-blowing we're trapped in a country
with imbeciles to continue guess what
when we get covet we don't end up in
hospitals so we don't overload hospitals
so what did i say we have no time for
idiots in our country anymore rogan has
yet to address stern's comments by the
way it's a couple things here one
you know howard stern's probably not too
happy that rogan's kicking us okay
that's number one let's just face it
used to say that podcasts aren't radio
yeah they're you know the other
day i watched a michael schumacher's
documentary i don't know if you guys
seen seen michael schumacher's
documentary if you haven't seen it it's
a must watch i'm a big sena fan if you
haven't watched schumacher's i've
watched cena's documentary a hundred
times watch humocracy that's an hour and
54 minutes
and he says some very interesting things
one of the things he said he said um
he said i don't like to brag about my
things because you'll call me cocky but
also don't talk about my weaknesses
because it's your job to find my meek
this is not mine schumacher says that
which is powerful to say that but then
there's a part of it
when
schumacher's coming up and he passes up
uh senna or senna gets a little bit
uncomfortable about it you know where
there's a you know schumacher takes the
cut you know cuts him off and senna get
loses his mind goes to schumacher
afterwards with his hand on his shoulder
you don't do something like this and
schumacher loses his mind saying i'm
just doing what you did to everybody
this is what you used to do play to win
the game you two people play to win the
game i'm doing that i'm doing what you
showed us to do right i think there's a
part of aston is not happy with the fact
that rogan's probably coming up and he's
taking his lunch and quite frankly
rogan's more attractive and more
uh versatile than a howard stern is i
don't know what howard stern does for
fun i don't know if he goes shooting you
know hunting ufc all this other stuff
people probably link rogue into more of
a man's man and howard stern is more
difficult more diverse you know he has
something to say on everything whereas
you know howard stern was a shock jock
you know and he's turned into whatever
he is now so i i did i used to do a
couple shows with jackie the joke man
martin who was with howard stern yeah
and there was a dude who wanted to do
this investment and i was like i don't
know and
we were in times square this is
anecdotal he'll probably say i'm lying
it's 100 true we're in times square okay
people were going by i wanted to show
them the power of social media and
digital media and the snap people were
going by i would just grab them real
quick hey can i ask you a question like
what's up i'm like do you know how much
stern is and guys that were over 40
you'd be like what is this stupid
question of course i know i would start
this i was like oh my bad then i'd grab
somebody that was like 25 year old i'm
like hey man you know how it started
they were like nah i don't know who's
howard stern like they would have no
idea if you went around this office and
we work in media and everybody here is
on the news all day
anybody under 30 years old i would i
would bet one in 10 would know who
howard snyder is but know what he does
could name one thing that he's famous
for
meanwhile how many people in that office
under 30 know what joe rogan is
everybody so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]